welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this last section of this chapter we
talked about
applications and implications of special
relativity we talk about the global
positioning system
you all have used gps
before beat in your car when you're
trying to find
your way through town or you know when
you go for a run and you want to measure
how long and how fast you actually are
running
the global positioning system is a set
of satellites all equipped with atomic
clocks and they're used for navigation
and have been developed
first under the name of navstar gps
and gps is one of many global or a few
global navigation system
others are clonas
bds galileo are systems
developed in europe in russia in japan
and so
this picture here shows you um you know
how you want to view this we have earth
and then at around 20 000 kilometer
kilometer um gps has about 31 satellites
which
zoom around the earth
and as soon as you have three satellites
which you can see from your viewpoint
you can actually figure out where that
viewpoint is
think about you know each satellite
gives you an information of a sphere the
cross-section between two spheres is a
line and if you have three c three s
crossing that gives you uh three
dimensional information about the
location on which you're looking at this
gps was first the first satellites were
launched in
1978 again 31 satellites are in orbit
at the right at the time right now
um so how this how does this work so the
satellite that transmits information
about position and time in regular
intervals so they have a clock they have
you know use a specific frequency or
multiple frequency to send send signals
and then the receiver
calculates how far away the satellite is
and how long it took the message to
arrive
at the place of the receiver
again three satellites are used to
extract the
exact location
however as you can imagine the reason
why i bring this up in this class is
that we have to consider effects of
special relativity
and also general relativity as we will
discuss later in this class
so you have clocks on
the satellites and you have identical
clocks on earth and they do tick
differently as we discussed many times
in this class
if you were to calculate the effect of
special relativity
the prediction is that the clocks tick
about
seven microseconds a day slower
on the satellite than compared to the
one on earth
however
the satellites are the high orbit
and the
gravitational pull at a higher orbit is
less strong as on earth and that then
has a
the results that the clocks on the
satellites actually run faster than the
ones on earth and that effect is larger
way larger than the effect of special
relativity which is effect from from
then just moving relative to the
observer
the effect is 47 microseconds a day and
then you can just calculate
the net correction which is 38
microseconds a day
which corresponds to about 11 kilometers
now imagine you know you run
on your run and there's 11 kilometer
difference a day i don't expect you to
run for a day but you might run for an
hour still the effect is rather large so
you want to have a more precise system
and therefore those effects need to be
corrected and there are they're
typically built in into their
electronics and automatically corrected
the precision achieved with gps's gps
system ranges a little bit
based on how you use the information
what kind of transceiver you use it's in
the order of 505 meters to 30
centimeters so about this
of a distance so anywhere on this planet
you can pinpoint your location by about
this
this is this precision
okay
so this concludes the discussion of
implications and applications
in special relativity